ready ah action
when we start secret Invasion Nick Fury has been
off planet and Maria Hill has just really been
trying to you know maintain order but this
current threat is getting out of control
and it comes back having lost whatever power he
had before I'm corjandro I'm here with the real
rejects sitting down with the director of all of
secret Invasion Ali Salin how you doing today man
great how are you I am obsessed with your show so
I'm very well wow thank you I've loved each girl
since I was a kid so you've really done honor
to my childhood I appreciate it fantastic so
from knowing you're working in treatment I noticed
immediately this amazing dual scenes between these
two actors that feels like they're dueling these
Great Character work pieces what was the process
like in rehearsal what was it like playing on set
with these powerhouses who are you referring to
uh with Sam and Don Cheadle Sam Olivia yeah
yeah everyone's just got these these scenes
great scenes great really well written scenes long
scenes meaningful scenes and you know all actors
are different in terms of what rehearsal means
to them and how they want to approach it and my
job was to sort of balance those different needs
right Olivia has very different needs than Sam and
Sam has very different needs than Olivia and they
were very excited to work together and so my job
is less about what do I do for them and how do I
create an environment where the both work a lot of
times people say how did you learn how to direct
and I say from coaching Little League because I
had 12 different people with 12 different needs
and I had to you know get them all to hit the ball
I had to pinch myself many mornings when I would
step on set with Olivia Coleman Sam Jackson Don
chill Emilia Clark Ben Mendelson Kingsley benedir
I mean some of my favorite actors in the world
Marvel's always cast really well but I feel like
some of these scenes are some of the best in the
whole MCU and seeing Ben Mendelson get the flex
and seeing a lot of this work and I've also loved
The Duality and dichotomy of the Scrolls whether
it's the color palette or the use of some language
the the way their antagonist and protagonist
and I feel like the show really mirrors that
with literal mirrors with your use of purple and
green colors with blue and red there's all this
imagery of Duality how intentional was that in
previous or was that something you put in the
script like how did that come about to visually
use so much dichotomy oh interesting I mean I
think it's a show about dichotomy and so every
step along the way that's what we talked about
the cinematographer the production designer
everybody talked about how can you show two
sides of everything how do you show you know the
production designer is great about talking about
colors primary colors secondary colors how do you
put them in how do you work them in the purple
blood is a great addition it's just a rule we came
up with that when they die their their blood turns
purple and it's great because you know green and
purple and that's so distracting uh did I answer
your question oh absolutely I was wondering just
it was from the beginning and it was throughout
the whole team yeah it's uh you know you read it
in the script and then you're like okay how do we
visualize it okay what references do we use okay
which production designer is going to bring this
to the table we get to jump into Nick Fury's
World which is very spy versus spy the kind of
grittiness the locations the way it feels the way
it's written it's a thriller the opening of this
has to cover so much because you've got Decades of
lore you've got the Scrolls being reintroduced as
antagonist now you've got to cover a lot densely
what was the pressure like in being brought onto
the show to have the opening be that strong
for a new show with beloved characters oh I
don't feel any pressure oh great yeah you just
you you find a way to tell the story that that
makes sense and ultimately that's all it is it's
just Clarity emotion purpose everybody understands
and then you've got that but I it doesn't feel
like pressure to me to maybe for the fans you
know you have to you have to deliver something
for them uh and there is a certain amount of
pressure to do that but just in terms of working
with the actors no it's all just storytelling
for years you've been avoiding Earth
I have called for your help plenty of
other times and you've been pretty content
to let those calls go straight to voicemail
yeah well this is different and speaking of
the actors I feel like this is the deepest
we've dove into Nick Fury and I feel like
that with the emotional Resonance of not
only Captain Marvel but also it feels like end
game this feels like a sequel to both of those
things what was the process of going through
this with Sam because I know he's a producer
on it as well what was the conversation was
it collaborative how long ago did you come on
and what's it been like working with him on this
character well I've been on for 28 months which
I don't think is the whole run I think people
have been on this for five years four years
um Sam's great he's a collaborator he knows Nick
Fury better than anybody knows Nick Fury but he
doesn't know this Nick Fury because he's never
explored it and so it was a great opportunity
to be able to explore it with him as Nick
Fury went home and Nick Fury went internal
and examined his fears and doubts and demons and
and Sam was very collaborative he understood what
was in the script but he also brought a lot
of his own personal stories to it that were
that you see on screen he's telling him it's
really seen in the trains wonderful brilliant this
idea of who can you trust that is really the heart
of the show you could be talking to somebody who
have a very close relationship with and then you
find out that that's not who you thought it was
it becomes sort of a cat Mouse game that we
we build toward to the end of the show my last
question for you with the Scrolls there's so much
secrecy and one of the big things in the comics
years ago was like Jessica Drew be revealed and I
love I love the show of what if and what can they
do did you have to do anything like scream where
you film the fake thing or alternated things or
had something as a mislead for any of the cast or
crew is there anything you had to double down on
no we did we didn't and I I um we never felt
like we were shooting spoilers out in public
right and we never felt like we were shooting
spoilers that anybody on the set would reveal so
perfect we know no decoy scenes amazing you
didn't have to you can't predict it and you
can't preempt it and you can't fathom it until
it happens I'm Nick Fury even when I'm out I'm
here well I adore the Scrolls I love what you've
done this is the most mature Marvel show I think
I've ever seen and I love these characters since
I was a kid so I really appreciate it thank you
looking forward to hopefully things getting
super with the Scrolls and the way you've
set things up to feel plausible in this world
is so appreciated thank you have a great day
fewer Since You've Been Gone
thank you things have gotten much worse
oh you think I came back
you're in no shape for this
fight that lies before us friend
this is personal very few of us know about
the wars fought in the shadows
that have raged on this planet
you feel responsible
where are the Avengers
this war is one I have to fight alone
you're the most wanted man on the planet
you don't know what they have planned for you
the Great Neck Fury
one last fight